hey guys so pilot season continues here
a wisecrack so this one is special to us
for a couple reasons first of all this
is the first time we're gonna be talking
about real-world events rather than
focusing on media secondly we are
bringing the vision of one of my
favorite artists to life as a girl went
to college with her name is Tyler rice
and we're super excited to have her
asked that it could be part of the
wisecrack family but also I wanted to
introduce the voice of this pilot Jacob
who is my co-founder who created
wisecrack with me about four years ago
hey guys we're really pumped to get this
out to you guys to let us know what you
think in the comments and make sure you
let Larry know - see you guys later
enjoy the show have you seen the news
lately
it sucks today's media landscape gives
people more ways than ever to hear only
the things they want to hear when
confronted with ideas that challenge
their beliefs many react with outrage
censorship and recently cries of fake
news this trend may seem to have popped
out of nowhere but this was actually
predicted a long time ago in a book you
probably read Ray Bradbury's Fahrenheit
451
in case you slept through middle school
English the book depicts a dark future
where firemen have graduated from saving
cats - torching books in an attempt to
silence any troubling ideas furna is
usually interpreted as an attack on
government censorship especially since
Bradbury wrote the book in the midst of
McCarthy's war on communism but there's
actually someone else Bradbury blames
for the dystopia his characters live in
you felt not only you but all of us see
in the book the main characters informed
that it was the public that censored
themselves it all started with the
advent of mass media technology advanced
to such degree that people struggled to
keep up information rushed in from every
direction overwhelming the population to
quell their anxiety people focused on
smaller pieces of information
Beaty captain of the firefighters
describes this change how media's been
reduced from cumbersome novels to the
gag the snap ending one column two
sentences a headline then midair all
vanishes just like that we consume and
forget and consume again rinse wash
repeat the mind drinks less and less
soon people became addicts conditioned
to feel pleasure from frivolous content
anything thought-provoking became
downright painful as a result people
censored themselves from any challenging
ideas they sought to be pacified numbed
and validated soundbites factoids and
vapid drama blaring out any troubling
ideas blaring out reality we see similar
patterns with the rise of social
networking and the feed news story after
news story that generates as you scroll
video after video meme after meme
directly fed and programmed specifically
to your liking just as long as you
continue scrolling in Fahrenheit the
media concluded that it could attract
the biggest audience by ridding itself
of anything controversial effectively
ceding control of its content to outrage
our media saturated Society is an
extension of Bradbury's vision with so
many different channels streaming
services and websites media has
fragmented each appealing to their own
individual audiences Fox News for
conservatives MSNBC for liberals and
YouTube for flat-earthers yet each of
these media outlets must pander to their
audience which is why Fox News can't
piss off mainstream Republicans
evangelicals and NRA members and MSNBC
can't piss off mainstream Democrats
progressives and gun control advocates
the result is isolated bubbles that
become harder and harder to burst
it's like Beatty said offend as few as
possible
the truth is secondary to comfort and
once someone finds their bubble they'll
label anything that challenges their
ideas as fake news both in the book and
in real life people protect themselves
from anything that confounds or upsets
they just want to continue watching and
scrolling and watching and scrolling and
watching and scrolling
so what happens next in Fahrenheit it's
here that the government steps in
encouraging everyone to stay in the
bubble and torch any stragglers
sometimes literally are we destined for
a similar fate or will the champions of
free thought save us all
[Applause]
[Music]
all right hope you guys enjoyed that let
us know what you think in the comments
below and also if you want to see a
pretty close to final cut of our next
pilot coming out join us over at
wisecrack plus com it's our patreon page
where we're always uploading new cuts
and stuff and asking our patrons for
feedback and it's a great community so
we love if you guys are a part of it
that's right because of all of you guys
all of our patrons and our fans are able
to make all these really cool pilots to
work with some amazing artists and
animators and musicians so thanks so
much be sure to check out our pilots and
we'll catch it the next one thanks guys
peace
[Music]